[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le journal de
tv 78 nous sommes le jeudi 2 décembre
voici les titres
un centre d'essai du véhicule propre la
société f v basée à trappes ites les
prototypes de batteries et de moteurs
électriques hybrides ou à hydrogène
avant leur mise en production elle
ouvrait ses portes ce jeudi à l'occasion
de la semaine de l'industrie
et de la production vers le
reconditionnement de véhicules
d'occasion depuis septembre l'usiné
renault de flins sur seine a entamé sa
mue un projet baptisé factory et
dirigeant du groupe au losange sont
venus inaugurer cette semaine les
premières avancées du dossier visite du
site dans cette édition
et puis cette table ronde organisée hier
au vésinet consacré à joséphine baker un
hommage au lendemain de sa
panthéonisation au programme découverte
des livres autour de ces mille vies en
présence de l'un de ses fils adoptifs
on parlera également tout à l'heure de
ce rapport rapport révélé par le
collectif handicap 78 qui fait état de
dysfonctionnements en matière d'accueil
et aussi de respect des droits des
personnes handicapées dans le
département à qu'elles soient enfants ou
adultes on en parle tout à l'heure mais
avant de développer ces titres on
connaît les finalistes du congrès les
républicains valérie pécresse et eric
ciotti s'affronteront au second tour de
cette primaire interne pour déterminer
le candidat du parti pour les élections
présidentielles le député des
alpes-maritimes en tête recueille 25 59
% des voix la présidente de la région
ile de france élu dans les yvelines
obtient elle 25% scrutin très serré
suivent dans l'ordre derrière ni celle
barnier 23 93 % xavier bertrand à 22 36
% et philippe juvin 3,13 % tous sont
appelés à voter pour valérie pécresse au
second tour sur le premier tour réservé
aux seuls adhérents et du parti plus de
110000 votes ont été comptabilisés soit
un taux de participation de 81,80 9%
les 140 mille adhérents sont appelés à
voter pour le second tour entre vendredi
8 heures et samedi à 14 heures le
résultat sera annoncé dans la foulée
[Musique]
dans le cadre de la semaine de
l'industrie ffv basée à trappes ouvrait
ses portes pour une visite de ses locaux
spécialisée dans les moteurs électriques
ce centre d'essais tester les prototypes
de batteries avant la mise à prix en
production les moteurs également 1,2 à
ses véhicules propres le résultat et le
reportage de bixente mérias entité man
lanthane fb de trappes c'est avec celle
de rouen l'un des deux centres d'essai
français de l'entreprise f v autrefois
testeurs de moteur thermique elle s'est
convertie récemment vers l'électrique en
2011 on a eu un premier centre d'essai
batterie mais limiter en taille
typiquement pourra aider renault a
développé la zoé et puis ça s'est
accéléré il ya trois ans en 2018 on a eu
des demandes de partout et puis on a on
est passé d'une activité thermique pur
et un peu de batterie à une activité
100% électrique à saint quentin en
yvelines aujourd'hui des techniciens et
ingénieurs travaillent essentiellement
sur les batteries et moteurs de leurs
partenaires avant la production et des
tests très rapide en général de ce qu'on
appelle les tests de performance on
vient tester les performances d'une
batterie soit d'un moteur électrique et
puis à des tests beaucoup plus longs des
tests d'endurance sur les moteurs
électriques c'est facile l'endurance
d'un moteur électrique c'est du
vieillissement réel est clairement un
moteur électrique posé à l'arrêt en
attente y élus ne vieillit pas de plus
en plus la question se pose du futur de
l'électrique pour alfred arpin il est
compliqué d'évaluer avec précision sa
part dans l'industrie automobile de
l'avenir il ya à la fois d'un côté les
décisions politiques qui font qu'on va
dans un sens c'est y aller
le rationnel technique qui fait qu'on
peut aller dans un autre sens il faut
qu'on arrive aujourd'hui bien échanger
entre nous tous pour converger pour
étudier les technologies embarquées à
feu et possède également un attrape un
service mobilité intelligente entre
connectivité assistance conduite
systèmes de recharge ils travaillent sur
ces nouvelles technologies l'idée est de
d'aller de plus en plus loin dans ses
différentes fonctions le problème étant
bien sûr le coup embarqué de tous ces
systèmes qui nécessitent d'être validée
d'être sur fb étudient aussi la question
de l'adaptabilité du véhicule il sera
probablement question dans le futur
d'acheter une voiture dont le moteur est
adaptée selon son usage quotidien ou
ponctuelles pour des courtes ou longues
distances
toujours en matière d'industrie cette
semaine les dirigeants de renault
groupes sont venus inaugurer les
premières annonces et du projet de l'ars
factory à l' usine de flins sur seine à
l'activité de reconditionnement des
véhicules d'occasion est opérationnel
depuis septembre dernier et découvertes
avec nicolas d'andry patrick jacques de
dixmude et maxime là il y en a pas deux
comme ça n' a pas deux comme ça là vous
avez jeu de livange pense est usée sera
à jour la première usine d'économie
circulaire dans l'automobile c'est la
grande ambition des dirigeants de
renault groupe autour de l'art factory
le basculement de l' usine de flins sur
seine vers un site d'économie circulaire
d'automobiles le premier pôle de ce
projet est déjà concrétisée avec la
factory vo un service de
reconditionnement de véhicules
d'occasion destiné aux concessionnaires
on a pour cela une application qui
reliait au tout système d'information de
la factory il nous affecte
la rénovation de la véhicule en quelques
clics et choisit le niveau de prestation
qui veut pour son véhicule les time
complet pour ce process aujourd'hui dans
le rennes c'est à peu près 21 jours là
nous on vise ont dix 10 jours de bukavu
et deux d'entre l'entrée du procès c'est
la faute au esse qui est le moment de la
mise en vente c'est plutôt huit jours
dès l'arrivée de la voiture sur site le
process de rénovation commence par une
série de diagnostic sur l'état du
véhicule regarde c'est pas des anomalies
ou des capes qui sont débranchés ou
tout autre état détérioration en fin de
compte et si cet art est détériorée par
on en voit ça pour la mécanique pour
faire l'appareil remettre les véhicules
en état vient ensuite la partie concrète
du reconditionnement sur quatre lignes
le site est organisé comme une usine de
montage avec les différentes étapes à
partir du diagnostic les réparations
sont réalisés si vous voyez là le
matricule de la voiture qui viendront je
croise celle là bas il ya le filtrage
filtre à air et liquide de frein et tout
ce qui a à faire il faut qui suit tout
ça et après que je suis ce qu'il a fait
pour vraiment la voiture et les
suédoises du ska qui sur d'or tu skies
affaires et même les commentaires si on
voit quelque chose on passe commentaires
pour l'autre koné qui va prendre la
suite la suite c'est la carrosserie la
peinture les contrôles qualité et
techniques avant un essai routier des
photographies sont réalisées à envoyer
aux concessionnaires pour la vente du
véhicule 1500 véhicules ont déjà été
reconditionnée depuis le mois de
septembre l'objectif est fixé à 45 mille
véhicules par an et ici on est en train
de développer un projet assez innovant
assez unique et qui nous permettra de
corps déjà 2 voilà de te donner une
nouvelle vie à 7
usine glorieuse auquel on tient beaucoup
et aussi ça nous permettra de comprendre
le siad vraiment du business dans
l'économie circulaire 700 collaborateurs
travaillent déjà pour l'art factory
l'arrêt de la production automobile est
prévue à la mi 2024 à l'horizon 2030
3000 personnes travailleront sur le
nouveau site de flins sur seine
la cybersécurité un secteur en plein
développement et qui a besoin de talents
ce samedi l'école européenne de
cybersécurité de versailles organise ses
portes ouvertes c'est de 10h à 17h
l'objectif c'est de faire découvrir sa
formation au métier d'opérateur en
cybersécurité les détails dans cette
interview express menée par nicolas
landry
l'école européenne de cybersécurité du
bertagne c'est une formation qui a comme
objectif de former des opérateurs en
cybersécurité reprend des gens qui n'ont
pas du tout de passer informatiques qui
sont des débutants complets et en deux
ans de scolarité on les amène un diplôme
officiel d'état qu'on appelle la petite
reine cp d'opérateurs en
cyberpsychologie
l'objectif de le cs de versailles c'est
de former ces gens là et les gens qui
vont passer dans notre école vous
rentrez donc dans cette chaîne et de
manière certaine on peut affirmer que
les gens qui parce qu'on dans l'école ne
seront plus jamais au chômage après
pourquoi il ya une telle urgence parce
qu'en fait c'est ça la guerre de demain
c'est pas forcément une guerre 100%
militaire comme on peut la voir dans nos
livres d'histoire c'est une guerre qui
ne se voit pas qui est une guerre
numérique
l'idée ça va être de présenter à des
jeunes un parcours dans le domaine de la
cybersécurité est ce qu'on appelle le
cyber combattre on va leur montrer un
film qui n'a pas été montré au grand
public qui est en tête une film
d'animation sur une opération spéciale
qui concerne justement un pirate
informatique et on leur présente puisque
c'est un parcours complet à deux
employeurs possible c'est à dire le
commandement de la cybersécurité de la
gendarmerie nationale qui sera présente
et le commandement de la cyber défense
de l'état major des armées
[Musique]
tu es moitié témoigner mais aussi
alerter sur les dysfonctionnements
rencontrés par les familles d'enfants et
les adultes en situation de handicap
dans les yvelines et le collectif
handicap 78 dévoilé ce matin les
enseignements de son rapport sur la
situation dans le département c'était à
versailles à la permanence du député
didier baichère qui est avec nous par
visioconférence bonsoir bonsoir député
de la première circonscription des
yvelines et emmanuel du collectif
handicap soit 118 est également avec nos
bons soirs
expliquez-nous déjà emmanuel ce travail
collaboratif qui a été mené votre
collective le précise a été créé il ya
quelques mois il est composé de 44
parents et usagers combien de personnes
ont été interrogées pour ce travail et
qu avez-vous demandé à ces personnes
alors en fait nous avons constaté sur le
terrain qu'il y avait beaucoup de
remontées de dysfonctionnements
individuel que ce soit sur les réseaux
sociaux de bouche à oreille donc nous
sommes formés en collectif ils nous
avons créé des sondages des sondages en
fait sur la partie pôle enfance mdph
pour comprendre de manière détaillée les
problématiques ainsi que sur celui du
pôle adulte qui toujours en cours et
également sur l'école inclusive
on précise juste mdph ces maisons
départementales pour les personnes
handicapées alors justement ce travail
collaboratif qu'en est il ressorti
qu'est-ce que vous avez constaté au
travers de ce travail alors que ce soit
pour l'école inclusive au problème des
péages nous avons constaté qu'il n'y
avait qu'elle avait un manque de respect
de certains droits et également pour un
manque de sécurité et de précarité vous
avez des familles des personnes en
situation d'handicap donc de vrais
dysfonctionnements ou etc ont été
constatés c'est bien ça oui oui
j'aimerais dysfonctionnements qui sont
récurrents effectivement didier baichère
votre vision justement sur ces
constatations de constater qu'au sein de
ce département des yvelines il ya
justement des dysfonctionnements en
matière d'accueil en métier en matière
de respect des droits des personnes en
situation de handicap quel est votre
votre réaction suite à ce constat
moi je veux dire que j'ai été très
frappée quand le collectif a pris
contact avec moi il ya plusieurs mois on
a eu l'occasion de se voir à plusieurs
reprises et j'ai dû rencontrer à peu
près une trentaine de familles à travers
ces réunions et j'ai été très frappée en
fait que chaque famille raconter la même
histoire les mêmes difficultés même si
le handicap était différent la même
solitude face à l'ampleur des démarches
administratives et la solitude vis-à-vis
du parcours à accomplir qui n'est pas
connu et qui n'est pas accompagné donc
une vraie lacune en termes
d'accompagnement ce qui est d'autant
plus frappant que la problématique du
handicap et pas forcément lié à une
problématique de moyens ou d'argent je
voudrais rappeler rapidement que l'état
le budget de l'état c'est 51 milliards
chaque année donc plus de 2% du pib qui
est consacré à la politique de handicap
et encore cette année moi je suis membre
de la commission des affaires sociales
nous avons voté une augmentation de 600
millions d'euros du budget pour le
handicap particulièrement d'ailleurs
pour revaloriser les salaires des
accompagnants qui travaillent dans le
domaine du handicap je pense qu'à une
vraie par mois ce que ce que j'ai trouvé
très intéressant dans le travail de ce
collectif déjà c'est de se rassembler de
se mettre le collectif pour éviter que
chacun soit que chaque famille soit seul
face à l'éducation nationale où seul
vis-à-vis en face du département et
puisse faire bénéficier les uns les
autres de leur expérience d'une
meilleure compréhension des étapes qui
avaient à parcourir et puis essayer de
nous un dialogue j'ai compris qu'il y
avait une volonté de co-construction
très forte et de nouer un dialogue avec
l'éducation nationale et avec le
département pour que clairement les
choses changent j'ai entendu une volonté
de faire changer les choses dans le sens
positif et être un interlocuteur de
poids vis-à-vis de ces deux institutions
emmanuel didier baichère dit que ce
n'est pas forcément une question moyens
justement à quels sont les axes
d'amélioration vous avez identifié des
pistes concrètes qui pourraient
améliorer les choses déjà dans dans un
premier temps dans un premier temps
c'est vraiment déjà d'avoir un échange
riche avec que ce soit le département
pour l'un des ph ou la ds de haine pour
qu'on puisse mettre en place des actions
en intelligence collective c'est à dire
par exemple avoir un partenariat avec
les associations qui ont développé une
expertise dans le recrutement et la
formation des accompagnons puisque
actuellement il ya un manque cruel de
recrutement des agresseurs ne s'est
peut-être pas forcément un manque de
moyens ça peut être aussi parce que est
ce que la personne se sent réellement
formés ils ont besoin d'être outillés
voilà on peut proposer des solutions
adéquates ça peut être aussi il ya plus
de 80 personnes qui ont été sondés pour
mdph fonction le pôle enfance sur 80 %
ne sont pas satisfaits sur 77 personnes
qui est quand même représentatif ils
éprouvent des difficultés sont
généralisés c'est à dire ne pas avoir
accès par exemple à ses droits comme
d'avoir un pc c'est à dire un plan
personnalisé de compensation un pps pour
les enfants c'est à dire un projet
personnalisé de scolarisation qui sont
obligatoires aussi par la loi et dans ce
cas là nous serons propose également ses
pouvoir être présent en cdaph donc en
commission pour représenter les usagers
et dont ceux qui iront un suivi en
libéral c'est à dire pas en cmp ou
institutions mais qui ont pris du
libéral a compté et très rapidement pour
terminer avec vous didier baichère
emmanuel parlait peut-être de dialoguer
notamment avec le ds dn donc la ds dnc
la direction des services départementaux
de l'éducation nationale vous allez
pouvoir peut-être apporter votre aide
faire écho justement auprès de
l'inspecteur académique de ces
problématiques tout à fait j'ai écrit
dès hier
marie hélène aubert donc et la
vice-présidente du département en charge
des politiques de handicap et à l'udc
femmes donc élodée sdn pour une
éducation nationale en leur disant que
j'avais rencontré et j'ai avait
travaillé avec ce collectif et que je
les soutenais et que je souhaitais les
rencontrer pour qu' on puisse mettre sur
la table l'ensemble des problèmes encore
une fois pourquoi construire avec eux il
s'agit pas uniquement de dénoncer de
faire une manifestation il s'agit
vraiment de se mettre autour de la table
je souhaite accompagner ce collectif
autour enfin dans les réunions que
j'espère l'éducation nationale et le
département vont s'empresser d'accepter
merci d'avoir été avec nous didier
baichère député de la première
circonscription des yvelines va y
arriver et emmanuel a également membre
du collectif handicap 78 merci d'être
venus a livré les premiers enseignements
de ce rapport que vous avez menées sur
les dysfonctionnements qu'il peut y
avoir en matière d'accueil et en matière
aussi de respect des droits de ces
personnes handicapées dans les yvelines
merci d'avoir été avec nous
dans ce journal à présent le dernier
volet de notre dossier consacré à la
lutte contre les violences conjugales
dans les yvelines et comme au niveau
national les faits de violence contre
les femmes sont en hausse le tribunal
judiciaire de versailles est pleinement
engagée sur ce sujet au niveau de la
répression et de la prévention les
détails dans ce reportage de nicolas
landry
[Musique]
il ya plus en plus de signalements mais
on a dans les yvelines la chance d'avoir
une autorité judiciaire qui répond plus
vite et plus fermement
[Musique]
le traitement judiciaire on n'oublie
jamais le principe d'individualisation
de l'examen de la situation au delà de
l'individualisation des peines et que
donc dans toutes les décisions
comprennent elles soient adaptés en fait
nous pouvons orienter les affaires vers
le tribunal poursuit thomas dire
traditionnel est utilisée aussi tout le
domaine très très large des alternatives
aux poursuites qui constitue une
véritable prise en charge des victimes
dans un contexte différent
[Musique]
m
les alternatives aux poursuites
permettent notamment dans le cadre d'une
composition pénale de
d'accorder à une victime un téléphone
grand danger le téléphone grand danger
est à la main si je puis dire du parquet
et donc dans des cas où il faut agir
très rapidement dans le cas d'une
alternative aux poursuites on peut
mettre en place une protection
immédiatement le bracelet anti
rapprochement est quelque chose qui
suppose l'intervention d'un magistrat
puisque c'est une décision qui est très
lourde en terme d'atteinte aux libertés
et donc ça se décale un petit peu dans
le temps
[Musique]
où
oh
[Musique]
on
constate dans les faits qui a de plus en
plus de ce qu'on appelle des peines
mixtes c'est-à-dire une partie
d'emprisonnement ferme pour les faits
les plus graves avec un suivi derrière
ce qu'on appelle le sursis probatoire ce
sont des convocations régulières des
obligations à respecter a justifié et
puis une vision donc une vigilance
particulière pour ces dossiers on a un
travail à faire aussi nous en lien avec
la justice et de développer tout ce qui
permet des stages tout ce qui va
permettre l'hébergement des victimes et
des auteurs séparément bien sûr pour
limiter là aussi la réitération
après l'intronisation de joséphine baker
au panthéon une table ronde sur
l'artiste et résistante était organisée
ce mercredi dans une bibliothèque du
vésinet au programme découverte de livre
sur sa vie rencontre avec l'un des douze
enfants de sa tribu arc en ciel son fils
adoptif et jean claude bouillon becker
qui a rencontré justement mickaël
millero
24 heures après son intronisation au
panthéon le vésinet rang d une nouvelle
fois hommage à sa façon à joséphine
baker une personnalité qui a vécu dans
la commune de 1929 à 1947 une table
ronde sur les oeuvres écrites autour de
sa vie était organisée ce mercredi 1er
décembre
jean claude bouillon bakker le cinquième
fils adoptif de l'artiste avait fait le
déplacement
moi j'aime beaucoup cette ville je
m'étais juge était venu déjà ya quelques
années faire un débat et je trouve que
voilà liane réception enfin joe dassin
tivité toujours au rendez vous un cercle
blanc l'occasion pour le public de
découvrir une bande dessinée sur
joséphine baker c'était de raconter sous
forme de roman graphique la vie de
joséphine baker de sa naissance jusqu'à
sa mort et c'est un livre qui fait les
500 pages quand même donc c'est assez
aujourd'hui l'une des sommes les plus
importantes sur la vie de joséphine
baker un rendez-vous à guichet fermé
l'événement attiré une centaine de
personnes un engouement qui ne surprend
pas la commune il ya beaucoup
d'attractivité et quand on parle de
joséphine baker je pense pour deux
raisons la première raison c'est que
d'abord c'est une très grande dame qui a
fait beaucoup de choses à dame aux mille
vies et puis le deuxième point c'est que
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui a vécu
longtemps au vésinet donc pendant
pratiquement une vingtaine d'années dans
une très belle vie là qu'est la vie dabo
le beau chêne le cycle de rendez vous
sur joséphine baker se terminera ce
vendredi au vésinet une exposition d'une
douzaine de panneaux sur les souvenirs
de l'artiste est à découvrir dans le
hall de la mairie
noël approche et les communes lancent
peu à peu leurs traditionnelles
animations les enfants étaient au rendez
vous hier mercredi à montigny le
bretonneux à l'occasion du top départ
des illuminations dans la ville après un
décompte le maire et le président du
conseil municipal des jeunes ont appuyé
sur le bouton qui a mis en lumière
les décorations les propos recueillis
par patrick jacques de dixmude et céline
charles c'est l'allumage des
illuminations de noël sur la ville de
montigny et donc nous avons souhaité
faire ça en présence des enfants et en
présence du conseil municipal des jeunes
et donc elias qui est à mes côtés quel
président du conseil municipal des
jeunes alpilles et sur le bouton avec
moi pour qu'on puisse illuminer toute la
ville ça annonce aussi ce qui va se
passer sur le marché de noël ce week-end
où nous allons aussi il a apporté des
nouveautés pour enchanter les petits et
les grands avant de vous laisser c'est
un grand événement au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines falaise un
spectacle de la compagnie baro d'evel
qui sera présentée du 9 au 11 décembre à
ce grand théâtre et danse clown chant
lyrique et guitares rock le rendez vous
s'annonce haut en couleur ce qu'il faut
savoir avec céline charles
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité demain vendredi place
aux 7,8 week-end de l'actualité des
idées de sorties pour bien terminer la
semaine dans les yvelines belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]